okay good morning everybody and welcome
to this media conference with england
manager gareth southgate
following yesterday's ua for euro 2020
final
we'll get this media conference under
underway with a question from jerry cox
from haters morning gareth
um the morning after the night before 12
hours later
how do you reflect on what's happened on
and off the pitch and also on social
media over the last
12 hours um
well i i'm not not totally across
everything but um
you know my first thoughts this morning
are immediately with the uh
uh the boys that have done so well for
us
and uh the players have had an
incredible
um togetherness and spirit which i think
has brought
so so many parts of our country together
so
you know they should be and i i think
they are incredibly proud of what
they've done
um for some of them to be abused
is unforgivable really um i know a lot
of that has come from abroad
you know the people that track those
things have been able to
explain that um but not all of it and um
it's just not what we stand for we we i
think have been a
a beacon of light in bringing people
together
in people being able to relate to the
national team
and the national team stands for
everybody and
um so that togetherness has to continue
and we've shown
the power our country has when it does
come together and
has that energy and positivity together
we felt that from the fans
and um i'm incredibly proud of the
players
and as i said yesterday the
the game we we needed to win in 120
minutes
um we were a little bit short in that
period
um then it's my decision who takes the
penalties
it's not a case of players not
volunteering or you know more
experienced players backing out they
didn't have the chance that was my
choice
nobody else's um my my decision
to give the guys that took it the
penalties that they took
still got huge belief in them
so those those boys have done a
a brilliant job and uh we
we heal together as a team now and uh
we're there for them
and uh i know that 99
of the public will be as well because
they will appreciate
how well they've played picayo in
particular has been an absolute star in
this tournament
incredible maturity the way he's played
um
has brought a smile to so many people's
faces he's become
such a hugely popular member of the
group and uh i know
he's got everybody's support
thank you jerry next we'll go to dan
kilpatrick the standard
morning gareth your boss uh mark
burlingham said he'd like to give you a
new contract um i wondered if you'd have
had a chance to
to think about your future yet and
whether you might sign that
uh i don't think now's uh
an appropriate time to think about
anything
we've got of course to qualify for qatar
um
but i need some time to go away watch
watch last night's game again reflect on
the whole tournament
um you know i need a rest
um it's um amazing experience
but you know to lead your country in
these tournaments
is um takes its toll
and uh you know i i need a break now so
it's um yes i said at the time it's
great to have that internal support you
you hugely value that as a manager
um but also you know there's a lot
a lot to think through it's not about um
[Music]
finance in any way or commitment you
know i don't want to commit to anything
longer than i should
and i never want to outstay my welcome
so um
but so all of those things need
consideration before even thinking about
uh
sitting down and talking but you know i
as i sit here today
i would want to be taking the team to
qatar i feel that
we've made progress over the the four
years
um we've we've had a fourth place a
third place and a second place it's uh
probably as good as any other team in in
in europe by those that have won the the
the tournaments themselves but
for consistency it's it's right up there
so
um a lot of things we've done right and
we know
and that this team isn't at its peak yet
um
but that doesn't guarantee winning
because we know how difficult it is to
get back to
the stage we got to last night that's
why it's you know so painful to get so
close
thanks dan nicks we'll take a couple
from jessica creighton from sky sports
news
uh good morning gareth there were some
really big tactical calls that you made
throughout this tournament and
you know almost all of them seem to have
paid off
how do you reflect on what you've
learned
as a manager yourself and how you've
developed as a manager over the course
of this camp
well um look i think you're always
learning as a manager
um i've had the opportunity now to
manage some of the biggest games in
world football so
those games take you through an
incredible roller coaster and there are
so many decisions to make across the
four or five weeks um you're never going
to get them all right
and we would never claim to have got
them all right
and sometimes you win matches
despite certain decisions and sometimes
you lose matches when
maybe the they were still the right
decisions to make
so um it's
all all part of learning every every
coach every manager is going to reflect
on every game that they
take charge of and um be better for all
of the experiences that you go through
so that that process is is never ending
really
and when you reflect and you you know
you haven't had
an awful lot of time to reflect so far
but do you feel there are any decisions
you could have made
last night to change the results
um yeah i think i need to see
i need to watch the game back it's
two and a half hours pretty much
where so much has happened that to be
able to go through the timeline of all
that now is
is uh yeah
there's too much going on during the
game since the game to really
be able to reflect properly so i i need
time to do that it's always important to
watch it back
and uh to to give a true account of that
i think
one of the the big positives i think to
come out of this tournament was the
emergence of such young and exciting
players bakayo sakura of course calvin
phillips jaden sancho
what do you think they will take away
from this this experience and
and being part of this england camp
well we've wanted for a long time to
make playing for england fun make
playing for england enjoyable
um i think our players now have that you
know when they
when they come away with england i think
they've had a fabulous experience
they've
loved the adventure they've loved each
other's company
um they've got an incredible spirit it
is
you know it really is a club type spirit
and um the the younger ones especially
you know they
well all that all of this team can go
again there's no there's no doubt about
that but the young ones are
still two four years from from peaking
and uh we've got 18 19 20 year olds
who've
done an incredible job and had a great
insight into tournament football and
um and acquitted themselves so well
throughout so
there are i know as i reflect over the
coming days there are a huge number of
positives from that
and those players will uh
will be far better for for going through
um
so many important wins so many important
landmarks that they
that they set historic performances
in the main they they performed under
the huge pressure of
being at home for the majority of the
tournament being one of the favorites
um that was a far different uh situation
to the
team when we went to russia and they
dealt with that so well in the opening
game in the
game with germany in the semi-final for
a large part of the final certainly the
first half of the final you know they
they they dealt with that um and
we probably had a 20 minute period where
we didn't keep the ball
as well as we needed to just after half
time
but then even the rest of the game was
fairly even although we couldn't create
the clear chances that we've been able
to in the past and uh
part of that is because we were against
a team that have gone 30 games unbeaten
and some incredibly experienced players
and
a team that are probably just a little
bit further ahead than us
in their development and their progress
hello gareth can you hear me
hello um ultimately this is the first
team to reach a final in
55 years um you have to reflect and look
back on that but it seems that the
camp and yourself are struggling to
really embrace that
today is that just a show of how great
your ambitions are
yeah i think um i know in time
that we will you know we will have an
appreciation of that and i know
the messages we're all getting that are
underlining that
um but when you're
when you're in sport and you get to
finals you know that those opportunities
are so rare
and to be so close and um
to know what that's taken and to know
you've got to pick yourself up and go
again
that's that's very hard the day after
you know you you've
you've given everything and the energy
levels are low and
the emotions are drained so
we we will go again of course but
sometimes it's easy to say things like
oh you know
we can go on to guitar now and win and
you know it's a bit glib really it's
that's a long journey we've still got to
qualify we've still got
um steps to take and uh
yeah you've got all the complexities of
release of players throughout the
qualifying period and everything else
that you have to start that cycle again
so this has been fantastic to have the
time with the players that we get
uh to be able to work with the players
every day
really embed the culture embed our way
of playing um
those periods of what what you live for
as an international manager and of
course when it comes to the end it's uh
it's very difficult um i'd i'll take the
second question as we're limited on time
for everyone
um as chair of the fwa to thank
yourself gareth but also your
communications team andy who we see
today louisa greg anna joe callum the
many others
you really have changed communications
and how it works
with broadcasters with journalists
you've given us an enormous amount of
time
in a very pressured situation and we
truly appreciate that and many
journalists that couldn't have been
at the games because of covert as well
we'll find that hard but
you have gone out of your way we hope
that has helped the journey somewhat but
we
we do have to thank you for that and we
hope that many relationships can go
forward
in the same way no that's very kind i'm
very fortunate to lead some incredible
staff and
um you know you've highlighted the
guys in the communications department
but all of our staff
in all areas of special people and uh
that's why we've been able to create the
culture we have um
you know i'm fortunate i sit at the top
and and
as the leader you get all the praise but
the work in the background is
is phenomenal in all departments and um
it's a privilege to work with everybody
and we don't have the team we have
without that support
if i could have one more then it would
be about your coaching staff how
important
have they been in this journey
yeah it's um it's critical
you know the the the roles
are too big um for the manager to do
everything
the detail that we're able to go to um
we've had some consistency and we've had
some changes
within that group and um martin
margaretson
has has been with us you know through
the last
couple of campaigns and has done a
brilliant job we had graham and chris
with us this time which was
um you know added something different to
the to the group
and i'm grateful for what they did um
but i have to highlight steve holland
he's
um phenomenal coach phenomenal man um
it's the calls that between us at 11 30
at night
at times of the season when nobody's
thinking about england
with you know traveling back for matches
talking into the early hours trying to
plan things trying to
um get things right and um
yeah without his support and uh
the quality of his work there's no way
we could have got to the
stages we have in the last couple of
tournaments so i'm
fully indebted to what he's done thanks
gary uh next to john murray at bbc5 live
hi gareth um i i understand uh that you
need to see the match back
but i'm sure it's been going around in
your head over and over again
what what is at the forefront of your
mind about what
you might have done differently last
night
um well look i think
we picked a team because of a tactical
problem that italy pose
and areas of the pitch we needed to get
pressure on them and where we thought we
could hurt them
and i think for the first 45 minutes
everybody would agree that
that worked we didn't keep the ball well
enough for a 15-20 minute period
and we know that with midfield players
of the quality of verratti
georginio that is always going to be a
strength with italy so they are going to
have possession um
we were actually controlling the game
without the ball for long periods but
that period we were a little bit
more open we
then couldn't release that pressure by
keeping the ball which we had done so
well in the first half
we changed the shape which i think um
gave us a little bit more um
control but it did open up spaces
elsewhere so
any tactical change you you have
strengths
um and then there are weaknesses to any
system they
they went with a false nine for a period
which is difficult to to deal with if
your defenders step out they leave
spaces if they
stay in any tactical change you
you have strengths and then there are
weaknesses to any system
they they went with a false nine for a
period which is difficult to
to deal with if your defenders step out
they leave spaces if they
stay in then you get overloaded a little
bit in midfield so that's always a
really difficult problem for any team to
solve
and we didn't quite create the chances
that we would have liked to but you're
against the team who are
incredible in terms of their defensive
power
as a as a team not just the two
center-backs
so yeah there are lots of things that
i will reflect on of course we we we do
that after every game and
uh um that that is the right process to
go through
but until you watch the game in in
absolute detail then
i would be uh i wouldn't be giving you a
fully accurate
uh appraisal of that thanks john next
the faker offers a talk sport
hi gareth um jordan pickford jordan
pickford was superb last night
his contribution obviously easy to be
overlooked because of the
result in the end but he was excellent
he was i thought he had a brilliant
tournament i mean
there are a lot of players who come into
that category and um
you don't get to a final without so many
players having played well and that's
what happened for us
so um jordan has often been
you know the number of times i've sat
here and he's his place in the team has
been questioned and
uh he's constantly delivered for us
and uh this tournament i think was was
his best
run of performances for england and he
should be uh
hugely proud of that to concede two
goals in
seven matches um you know our whole
defense their whole team but of course
the goalkeeper was a big part of that
two saves in the shootout
so you know he he could do a little more
in terms of keeping the ball out of our
net
and um that's always the the starting
point for any goalkeeper
so yeah he had a a really outstanding
tournament
next to henry winter of the times
hi gareth gareth this is all very um
civilized for a post-tournament defeat
oh
are we in our england too nice to win
well um
i don't see that really
we've got to a final first time for 55
years
[Music]
yeah i'm not sure um
[Music]
not really sure what what
a team that gets to a final you you're
not a nice team to get to a final i
think we've
overcome a lot of hurdles that we've
never been able to in the past
um we know that
a lot of players that are still
very inexperienced in terms of
international football and
uh um and have delivered at an
incredibly high level
um the more experienced players
in the big matches were were really able
to
use their experience to to defeat
germany who
who had an incredibly experienced team
uh to come through a semi-final which
was a
hugely challenging experience for them
and we've taken it to the who are a top
top team
and an unbeaten in 30 right to the wire
so
if if we'd been torn apart or
or you know looked a mess then
i might be thinking differently about it
but um
of course we're going to analyze
everything but also we're going to be
realistic about that and not just
dive into things that aren't reality and
aren't the reason for
for not having one um it's easy to
throw theories around at the end of a of
any game
in in any number of areas but
i think it's important to really reflect
carefully and uh and analyze carefully
when when you're the coach because
um i don't i don't want to go along with
narratives that are that
probably aren't correct um but also i
have to reflect on
uh on everything that's asked which is
totally fair
martin samuel and daily mail
hi gareth um
italy have now won four world cups i
think it's the second european
championship
i know we've tried to play down history
and
everything um throughout the tournament
the significance of it
but is there something um
in what happened last night about the
fact it's it's 55 years it's so long for
us and the only way you really
overcome that is by getting to as many
finals almost getting to these
situations as many times as
countries like italy countries like
germany countries like argentina
do because they have experience of
winning they have experiences of losing
it adds massively to the the football
culture that those players inherit
yeah i i i think you're absolutely right
it's um
i remember when we looked back at
germany's winning 2014 they'd been to
semi-finals and um you know
semi-final in their own country when
they hosted 2006
and the pain of that but also the
experience of that and
yeah if you want sustained success as a
team
you have to constantly be evolving
constantly improving constantly
finishing in those later stages
and most teams that win you know france
went through what we're feeling now
2016.
germany did it as i said spain went
close a couple of times before they won
um that is normally part of the process
that you've that you have to go through
and
um the fact that we've had a you know
the first signs of some consistency
semi-final final
um has to be a step in the right
direction it's not
ultimately where we wanted to get to and
when you're so close that's even more
painful of course it's
you know just feels like stomach's been
ripped out this morning
but um i know
when my logical brain comes back to life
in a few days that
that is that is the process we have to
go through and we've got to keep
continuing that
um and england have to keep that track
going
you know whoever is here whoever is at
the fa whoever's at st george's park
that's what we have to build that's that
was the vision at the start
and we're showing the signs with with
the help of the clubs
who are producing some fantastic young
players um all of those things have to
align because
you know any part of that football
pyramid that isn't strong
um affects the national team and at the
moment lots of things are starting to
come together and we have to continue
that
uh john cross mirror
hi good morning um i was just really
going to um
ask you generally at the end of a
tournament
at the end of a tournament cycle you see
the end of an era
for a team um but you're hardly really
going to lose any players are you for
2022
you know you've maybe got a couple of uh
over 30s it
in a similar vein i guess it feels like
the beginning um
for this team doesn't it the gains
experience and this could be the
beginning of the journey
for a lot of those young players well i
think russia was the beginning
um you know we had
seven i think in the starting team last
night
from from russia and that experience
has been critical through the big
matches in this tournament so to add
the young players in at the times we did
the inexperienced players in at the
times we did
they've now there's another group with
with more learning more understanding of
that high level
um they will because of what they've
been through in these two tournaments
they'll want more
they'll they'll know they can get close
they'll have belief
and that's what we have to build on it
doesn't guarantee anything because of
course you have to start again and
you have to earn the right every time
you uh you take the field and every time
you go into a tournament but
the cycle and the expectation of the
group
when they come together now will be no
no this is this is how it works this is
how we
train every day this is what's needed
this is
where we what we need to do to get to
the level to win and
um that that should be a process that
stands us in good stead
next simon peach press association
morning gareth and i just like following
on from that really and
what what happened with the group and
are they gone now are they still
together did you have one last
meeting together and what support
processes are in place i know you said
last night that
it's about the collective rather than
the individuals but we've discussed the
sickening abuse aimed at some of those
players what support processes are there
for them
yeah we've got to make sure that we're
there and
aligned with their clubs and making sure
that we look after those boys absolutely
and
um that that's been top of my thinking
um all night really um
[Music]
sorry i've forgotten the first part of
the question simon
sorry it was just about what's happened
in terms of the players going their
separate ways have you have you met up
again
obviously there was a long period in the
dressing room last night
they then went to meet with their
families um
across the road um so they had you know
i'm told they had a nice
sort of evening together um i i managed
to see them all individually
for a few moments before they left the
dressing room because um
i knew everybody would be sort of
heading their own direction at the end
of the game
and um i just wanted to thank thank them
all for what they've given because
they've been
a joy to work with they really have
bought into everything we've tried to do
been totally unselfish in their outlook
they've all you know
given everything they possibly could so
i'm tremendously grateful for that and i
know the country is because
you know you you can sense from uh from
the reactions of people so
but yeah they're they're they're all
head on their way now um
they they need a break they need a rest
and uh
i hope they all have a fantastic summer
thanks simon uh next to matt done the
express
all right gareth um we've uh this is so
much different from the post-mortem
after the
last euros and like you said earlier two
semi-finals and a final now
uh makes us consistently one of the best
teams in europe
i think we've done that by um
anticipating what the opposition are
doing and adapting accordingly i just
found that by
2022 will we've been a position more to
imprint our own
identity onto games and perhaps with the
young town that we've got
see more of that attacking flair that
we've got on an individual level
coming through in in our sort of open
play and is that the aim
or is that going to be too soon for that
no it's
um that that has to be the aim um
i think some of those players are
not yet at that point of of their
evolution
to be cemented in the team and um
and i think also there are so many you
know even coming into this tournament
there are so many things that were
uncertain in
in terms of being able to embed one way
of playing
um the injuries we came in with the
availability that we came in with
um we weren't quite sure defensively
what what we were going to look with
um i have to say you know tyrone did a
fantastic job coming into
a massive situation at the beginning of
the tournament um
we we had that huge doubt over harry
mcguire at the start
and to have defended as well as we did
throughout the tournament
um without having been able to play that
back four together
too often really in the in the two years
before luke only came back in with us in
march
for one game he had a phenomenal
tournament i have to say as well
so we we were constantly dealing with
uncertainties we didn't know
you know calvin phillips amazing
tournament we we weren't sure we were
going to have him in the
the week leading into the first camp um
so remarkable year really
in in terms of trying to build something
consistent we never had the players
um all together until seven days before
the start of
the tournament itself and you'd you'd
like to have built
across the whole season but that wasn't
the realities of the season we had
um that should be the aim moving forward
um in some areas of the team we've got
clear strength and players who
were in form and in other areas of the
team
we don't have quite the same amount of
strength and we've had to do it
differently and do it our way
and by adapting and adjusting we've
we've managed to get to a final
so of course you're always looking for
perfection and we're always looking to
improve and we must continue to do that
thanks matt okay we're coming to the end
now so we've got time for a couple more
and starting with rob harris from ap
hi guys commiserations thanks for
everything food tourman um
does it frustrate you and are you
reflecting on how to tackle how you've
got players who've generated
such pride from the country during these
last few weeks but you're still having
to deal and address the fact there are
fans who are being disrespectful
offensive and violent and
and not the image that you want and
certainly completely counter to the
image that the players have presented
yeah i mean we can't control that
we can only set the example that we
believe we should
and represent the country in the way
that
we feel you should when you're
representing england and
everybody has to remember when they
support the team that they
also represent england and uh should
represent what we stand for so
um i think the the players have done
that brilliantly
and um we we can only continue
to try to affect the things that we can
but
we have i think had a positive effect on
lots of areas of society but
but we can't affect everything there
other people have responsibilities in
those areas
and you know
we've all got to work collectively to to
constantly improve those things
and we'll finish your question from ali
foster at the bbc
hi there gareth hi garrett apologies
um just as those players are really
hurting at the moment especially the
three that miss the penalties you say
you take their sort of collective
responsibility and responsibility as
well
how much does it hurt you that you
perhaps didn't get things right
about you talk about failing to solve
those problems that roberto mancini set
set you yeah look
um as a manager
you have to accept whenever there's a
defeat there's going to be
intense analysis of everything that
happened in the game and um
[Music]
we've benefited from a lot of
praise during the tournament and if we
didn't get that right last night
if i didn't get that right last night
then i have to accept that as well
so i think some of that analysis
could be accurate and i and i expect
some of it won't be um
but you know i need time to to reflect
on all of that
um it's uh
yeah you make hundreds of decisions in
the course of
a week in the course of a tournament
there are even more
and um you're not going to get all of
those right you you
you call them as you see them at the
time and um
you've got to get more right than wrong
and uh
if we didn't if i didn't get the calls
right last night
then uh then so be it i have to live
with that
sorry to disappoint the many hands
raised we're going to conclude it there
and i'd like to take this opportunity
to thank you all for your coverage
across the course this tournament
thank you thank you thank you very much
you